so let me start with an overview of all
of what is involved in our a general
overview of what's involved in our
control system design process
and then show what I'm going to put what
the stuff that I'm going to present how
it fits in so the control design process
itself is not really a rigidly
structured and different people and in
different industries the the process
could vary from a little bit here and
there but there are some common
components like for example the required
good okay so components like first
gathering the requirements modeling
design implementation testing and so on
and in some in some segments they
actually have this V diagram which is
basically the same thing - so they go
through the requirements they come up
with what the system design should be
the software this one comes in in some
like in automotive applications where
they where they want to get the things
faster into market and they are doing
these two things almost concurrently and
so on so what I'm going to present comes
in this software design design component
right that's what I'm going to be
presenting today so the stuff that I'm
going to be presenting is about
nonlinear control systems so this is
stuff that got introduced in Washington
and we've been adding stuff in control
systems since version eight we started
with linear systems and then we added
capabilities for systems with delays and
then algebraic constraints and now
nonlinear system so what I'm going to be
covering is this nonlinear systems as
the standard nonlinear systems not yet
delays in this will
and the standard linear systems come out
as trivial or a special case of death so
why is this important in one word it is
applications so you see if you concern
well-being in many applications where
where the system is not linear and there
is a good number of them where the
control input itself obviously nearly in
the system so there has been a lot of
development in in terms of understanding
nonlinear dynamics and control
techniques to handle nonlinear systems
but one of the bottlenecks was the
computation because the computation is
really heavy on Symbolics and what we
hope is achieved by this functionality
is it's going to ease some of that pain
and and it's going to make the whole
controller design process more efficient
ok so for the next three slides I'm
going to show the at the linearization
technique to design controllers so the
first one this is the most simple one
the Taylor linearization so we start
with either and a fine or a fine or a
nonlinear model so this is the the
equations governing and affine model so
this U is the input variable that's why
it's called affine because the input is
appearing linearly and this X is this
other state so this this first equation
is the state equation and then we have
the output equation in Mathematica this
is how you would define an affine model
which specify what the a vector is what
the B may be matrixes the C vector and
the D matrix or we can start with a non
linear model so in the non linear model
the input you need not appear linearly
so it's a completely nonlinear model in
both the states and inputs and similarly
the output equation is also completely
nonlinear in both inputs and outputs and
this is the this is the constructor for
the non linear state-space model in
Mathematica now to carry out the Taylor
linearization it is the same thing just
like how we would do for regular how we
would do for
on a nonlinear dynamical system we are
interested in small we're interested in
small deviations above the operating
point X naught and unit are the
operating points we are interested in
the dynamics that is close to those
operating points so once we set up these
variables we can we can from the
governing from these equations we can
find what the governing equations for
for these small deviations are by doing
a Taylor linear expansion and then we
neglect all the higher-order terms so
these jacobians turn out to be the ABCD
matrices of the linear system and and
this is the state space when this is we
already had since washing a this is the
state space representation this is the
constructor for a state space model so
here's the state space model I'm
linearizing a nonlinear model and you
can see the four jacobians there so the
whole idea is to do controller design on
this and the challenge is how good the
controller is because it will not be
good very far from far from the
operating point so let's look at that
with look at an example of training
linearization and action so I took the
standard example know for an inverted
pendulum so the whole idea is to keep
this Bob perfectly balanced so I start
with the governing equations so the
first equation is the force balance and
the second equation is the moment
balance so a final state space more
later also as the constructor where you
can you can directly give those
equations to a final state space model
and it will come up with the state space
representation so the other things are
so these this is the in the time
variable or the independent the temporal
variable these are my output equations
so these are the two variables that I'm
interested in as my outputs there are
other variables either they are inputs
or States so any function of time that I
that is it's either an input if it's not
an input then I specify it as one of the
states and it will automatically compute
what the state space representation is
so once I have this affine model I can
go ahead and compute the controller I'm
using state this is pole placement so I
want to place so this is unstable but
say for example I want to
place the poles at at these locations
the other thing is yeah yes so usually
usually the state feedback gains they
work for linear models so I should I
should actually do like this stick see
you see so this this is a linear
technique it's and it and it uses the
linear model and but we have automated
this process so you can directly give a
nonlinear model and it will come up with
the gains the only difference is in one
case it's a matrix this this is actually
the control log given as a as a list
because there's only one control input
there's only one element and the reason
it's like this is in case you have
operating points that are nonzero the
gains will not completely capture all
the information but both these will
automatically work with the next step
which is to put them which is to connect
the plant and the controller so if we
connect the plant and the controller
together this is the closed-loop system
of the unstable pendulum with the with
that controller and then we can simulate
it I'm starting with an initial position
of 30 degrees and I see that the
controller brings it back and if I if I
go much further it probably see it hangs
so it says that I mean this controller
is not good at places far away from from
really far away from from the operating
point the other thing is suppose I just
did a linear simulation I do not use the
full nonlinear model if I just did a
linear simulation the simulation will go
through but that is not really so with
these nonlinear models we are able to
get high-fidelity simulations and and
test the controller's better
and finally you may also be interested
in the control effort how much control
effort was expended in doing this and
and this is the way we do it so it's
just so this controller depended on
these following states
so we so we just get the get what the
state would state response of the closed
loop system is and plug it back into the
controller the negative sign is because
it's a negative feedback and we know
what the control effort is so so this is
the so that was tailored linearization
it just throw away all the higher-order
terms the next level of memorize the
technique we have this called column and
linearization this is also kind of
Taylor linearization but it retains more
information so there are two things and
so we start with I'm using a nonlinear
model for the illustration purposes the
complete nonlinear model there are two
steps so the first thing is we again
look at deviations from the operating
point but not we don't really throw away
the terms corresponding to the states
we're only looking at deviations of the
input and then we just do a serious
expansion of the state and all the
higher order terms in the input we throw
away the second thing we do is those
series polynomials that we choose as our
state's and by doing that and if you
work out the algebra it's pretty simple
so by doing that what we end up with is
a model that is linear in both the
states and the inputs there is this
cross coupling term so it's actually a
bi linear model but we have reduced this
completely nonlinear model to a bi
linear model and we hold this in in the
affine representation and then the idea
is to use this model to do controller
design so let's look at an example for
that okay this time I choose this
example so so this is a therapy for hit
the HIV infection so I have healthy
cells that the concentration is x1 the
the the Wireless the concentration of
the wireless is x2 and this is this this
is the governing equation for the for
both the healthy cells and the virus you
see the this is the production rate this
is the decay rate and so on it's a
pretty straightforward equation and and
then this control input is the dosage
level so if I have for example a very
low
if I have say a very low dosage level I
mean then then the virus is just going
to go up but suppose I have a very high
value it's going to go down but then my
healthy cells have moved out of the
equilibrium position and so on so the
whole idea is the whole problem is how
do I find what the correct dosage level
is yes so the other thing I have from
the source I got this they don't bring
the wire the infected cells they don't
bring it all the way down to zero that
they do this treatment in stages so that
the target is to bring it down to ten so
I'm going to do column and linearization
of that system so when I do column n
linearization I need to say how many
things how many stuff how much I want to
retain and so these I say that these are
the new state variables you can you can
see that there are multiple ways to
specify this in this case I've used that
and what this returns is a linearizing
transformation data so in the previous
example you saw that you had to put
together the plant and the controller
and so on so one of the advantages of
this transformation data object is once
you have this and you design the
controller in the new coordinates you
can automatically put everything
together
yeah so I come so from that data object
I compute what that what the transform
system is and I compute do I do a
controller design based on that
transform system this last time you
state feed by against now I'm using lq
regulator gains I get this controller as
you can see I can I can just once I have
this control I want to compute what the
closed-loop system is I'm putting I'm
doing of connection so this is the
automation so we so we just say
closed-loop system with this controller
and it will give me the complete flow
slope system and I can do the simulation
and I can see that you know the infected
cells have been brought down and the
healthy cells have reached
value and again because I have that
object I just want to know what the what
the original okay so because this
controller was designed in the new
coordinate so the controller we're
interested in is actually the controller
in the in the original coordinates so
that is the origin controller you'll see
it it's nonlinear because I have this
cross coupling term which I specified us
to start with and then again I I
substitute the state response and I get
the dosage level so yeah so the next one
then the next linearization technique so
in both knees the tailor and the
carlomon we will when we linearized we
lost some information about the about
the system in this linearization
technique we do not lose any information
about the system all the information is
stored in a transformation so I'll start
with a simple example to just show you
how this works
suppose we have this is a standard mck
system the mass these are all the
Coriolis terms the conservative force
terms the applied forces but it's
nonlinear because this X because these
are all functions of X now if I choose
the control input like like so like like
these terms and I substitute it back in
these in this new control variable the
system is now linear and I can do linear
controller design based on this new
system and then transform it back so
this is the idea behind the feedback
linearization so then the whole question
is if I have a general affine system
like this how do I find the
transformation and that's also pretty
straightforward we start by choosing the
first transformation as the output and
do successive differentiation so these
successive differentiations will give me
the transformation and there is an
assumption that this one term should be
0 I'll I'll I'll say what happens if
that that assumption fails
so this successive differentiations is
going to give me the transformation and
because it's successive differentiation
this is going to be the new dynamics and
the new dynamics are linear except for
the last term which is
nonlinear in X so then what I do is I
choose that to be my new control
variable and the moment I do that I get
a completely linear system but all the
linearization information is stored in
that transformation so in in block
diagram this this is the summary of that
so the yeah just don't worry for now
both the post and the pre compensator
that is more advanced techniques when
this doesn't work but we we this
relationship here between the old
control and the new control that is what
is captured in this feedback and that is
that feedback relation and once we do
the state transformation we get these
new we get this new system we should get
everything linear but if that assumption
fails and I said that this term should
be 0 if this assumption fails then it
could happen that there are some
residual dynamics left it is not
completely linear so we are good as long
as those procedural dynamics are well
behaved if it's not well behaved there
are some techniques to get around it but
for the more this for this talk I'll
just assume that those dynamics either
are non-existent or well behaved so let
me show an example for that what
feedback linearization so so this
example is is modeling the oscillations
in a compressor in action an actual flow
compressor and so the dynamics as such
are oscillatory so I'm going to use
feedback linearization to to suppress
those oscillations so I feedback
linearized that system again returns to
me this data so this data objects so
this data object has all the information
about the transformation and once I
descend my controller I can put it back
in the original coordinates I can get
more information about the about the
transformation and so on
see once that's evaluated I can do so so
these are all the properties we can get
what the state transformation was what
was the linear system that was obtained
what was the feedback compensator so the
so these are this and many other and
many other information we can get so I
get the linear system and I do a
controller design so this is the
controller in the new coordinates for
example if I am interested in what the
controller is in the original
coordinates let's just I'm just copying
pasting the one from above see so this
is the controller in the in the original
coordinates although in the in the new
coordinates we just did a linear design
and then just like before from that same
data object we can get the closed-loop
system and we can simulate it and see
that works ok so these were all
linearization techniques so now we have
so this is another controller that's
what are the functionality that's output
tracking so this problem is how do we
determine an output law that causes that
causes the system tools to follow a
trajectory we want the output of the
system to follow operating like a robot
arm or something we wanted to follow a
trajectory that we specify so this
technique is also based on the
linearized subsystem that we just
discussed and because it's the
linearized subsystem we should know how
many states have been linearized so the
only infamous so one critical
information that we have to know is the
number of states and that is given by
this property that's the vector relative
orders so we have a function for that
also so I'll explain that using this
example
so this is a biological pathway it's
it's involves the production of glucose
and so on and I want to maintain certain
metabolites at certain values so this is
the governing equation for that for that
system and now this is the function
asymptotic output tracker I give the
system I say what are the trajectories
it should track so here I use just
constant values in general they could be
functions of time and then I specify the
decay rates so how do I know how many of
these I should specify that's given by
the virtual aid waters so there are six
so which basically means this system had
six states and the the total of the
vector later waters is 6 so if I did
feedback linearization this whole system
would be linearized and that's why I
give 6 decay rates and then it's the
standard standard way to connect and
simulate we it's a state feedback thing
so we state feedback connect the system
and the feedback law and we evaluate it
and just as before we we compute we can
compute what the control effort is using
the state response function yet another
controller technique this is output
regulation so we want to maintain the
output of the system at a particular
value it could be that the system is
getting excited by some disturbances
that we have no control over and in the
presence of that disturbance we want to
we want to make sure that some some
variables in the system are maintained
at a certain level we could also use
this to model some trajectory that we
want the system to follow and then in
the presence of and we model that that
trajectory are appropriately and then we
say that this certain variable should
follow the trajectory
so the example I have here is is a level
control of a tank so the flow the flow
variable ism is in the top tank and I
want to maintain the level of at the
bottom tank at a particular value and
I'm going to say that there is some
disturbance over here some fluid is
either coming in or going out which I
have no control over and I've chosen the
going out as positive so so this could
be some so the whole thing now is how do
i model this disturbance I'm going to
assume that this is a slow system and
that I'm just for the first two
equations are that's the burning
Bernoulli's law for for the flow in the
two tanks and then the disturbance I'm
going to assume it's constant we're
going to assume I'm going to sample and
between each sampling period that it's
constant then we'll see how good the
controller phase so once I have that I
know what the operating points are just
like before once I have the equations I
can use non linear state-space model to
automatically construct the construct
the state space representation the final
state is just the disturbance and which
I'm assuming is zero and the function
that computes the controller is the full
information output regulator it's called
full information because it's just not
state feedback it also uses the
disturbance the what is the disturbance
to the system which is QD so in case in
this problem I assume you can we can
regulate like we can know what the
disturbances but in case it's not then
we have to also construct an estimator
for this controller and once we have
that again same workflow as before we do
a state feedback connect yeah well one
thing I should know so since version 10
we have we have introduced this kind of
functionality where we have we have this
kind of typesetting where we have scaled
it in case the it doesn't fit we we use
these glyphs to actually put so that
everything is is put within one page you
can you can you can browse or you can
your tool to perceive that expression or
you can click there to get the entire
expression okay so now I come to the
disturbance I assume that the
disturbance this is the disturbance it's
actually a polynomial but I'm going to
sample it at each time instant and then
I'm going to assume it's constant and
see how good my controller is doing yeah
oh the disturbance is a fine ago or that
X is actually time yeah so in the next
in the next variable I wanted to use X I
want to use time there so every want of
conflict yeah it's actually yeah yes so
once so I created this disturbance I
yeah I come up with this I just assumed
that that is going to be the disturbance
and then I take the closed-loop system I
assume that that is the disturbance I
simulate it and I see that it's in fact
work so I'm interested in the height the
second height which remains at 3 that's
what I wanted it to be in the other one
is just turned out to be 3 is just a
coincidence so just go 1 of 1 and s so
this is all the controller design
techniques I'm just going to go over
some analysis tools so one of the
analysis tools is controllability to see
if a system can go from one point to the
other in the state space so you won't
know if the control effort can take it
so this is this is a this is a vehicle
model it's a kinematic model the states
are the positions and the orientation of
the of the vehicle and this is the steer
angle and the control inputs are the
this is the dry velocity and the drive
drive rate of the steer rate if I do a
lynnium if I consider the I have to wrap
up but I just get through this slide too
so if I if I look at the linear model it
turns out that it turns out that the
system is not controllable but the
nonlinear model it's true and there's
two ways to understand that so
if you look at the simulations this is
like parallel parking your car it we
paddle park our cars and what it says is
that it's only using the nonlinear model
that we can we can see that the system
is controllable the linear model throws
away too much information and we cannot
see that it is controllable so there's
two ways to do it yeah okay so let me
just so so we can understand this in two
ways either using the simulation so
using the computations so using the
input we think what we do when we drive
a car we first drive and then steer
drive backward and then steer backward
and using these combinations of inputs
you'll see that the nonlinear model
actually moves from point A to point B
but the linear model does not so that
that nonlinear information is actually
important to capture that this system is
in fact controllable and you can see
that same information from a
mathematical perspective and that's
using this controllability distribution
I'm just going to skip this for now but
you'll see that this is the same thing
you do combinations of drive and steer
and you can get motions like slide and
wiggle and so on and you can see that
the distribution actually spans the
entire controllable space yeah so this
slide all I want to say is that it's
fully integrated all the nonlinear all
the nonlinear functions that we have
added it works just like for the linear
case so if you know how to work with the
linear it will work just like that for
the nonlinear so I'm doing state space
transformation you'll see that this
syntax is just the same as the linear
give the model instead of giving a
linear transformation which was only a
matrix matrix or a pair of matrices you
just give the nonlinear law so the whole
summary of the slide is it's very
integrated so to summarize the whole
talk the recent nonlinear control
systems are important is because of the
numerous applications and what I hope we
have done is is is make this process
more efficient by
by having this functionality which takes
away a lot of the symbolic tedious
symbolic computations and we also made
sure that it's it's it's done in a clean
and cohesive manner the the two main
functions that I used to capture the
models are affine and non linear
state-space model the controller design
techniques that we added are the exact
and approximate linearization output
tracking and output regulation the
analysis tools are many they they
include controllability observability
later water computation state
transformation etc and you can find more
information about these functions on the
on the guide page and also on the
marketing page